lever la main ce qui
son lever la main ce qu'ils savent que
ça parle d'une prostituée à y en a un
petit peu moins élevé la main ceux qui
savent pourquoi sting rigole au début de
cette chanson à un seul ok alors cette
chanson effectivement si roxane de
police elle parle d'une prostituée
effectivement lieu d'août pondent you
dude parente ude plant the red light
effectivement tu n'es pas obligé de
mettre la lumière rouge
cette lumière rouge en fait c'est ce qui
signale la présence d'un client chez une
prostituée
c'est assez étrange en fait parce que
cette lumière rouge c'est un système qui
existe par exemple dans des villes comme
amsterdam
et pourtant cette chanson elle a été
écrite à pigalle la bielle n'y a pas de
lumière rouge
non abidal sting est descendu dans un
hôtel et ils s'inspirent de ce qu'il
voit en bas de la rue
d'ailleurs dans le hall de cet hôtel il
ya une affiche de cyrano de bergerac
dans l'héroïne est proxad alors pourquoi
sting rigole au début du morceau fatigué
de la veille quand commencent leur
enregistrement
ils pensent s'asseoir sur un piano d'un
couvercle est rabattue et bien manque de
pot le couvercle n'est pas du tout
abattu cette chanson vous l'avez écouté
plein de fois et peut-être n'avez-vous
pas pris conscience que les fesses de
sting jouait pourtant sur ce morceau
cette note a été conservée parce qu'elle
ne détonnait pas par rapport aux
morceaux écoutés
page 2
des histoires ce fut même le fils de ma
construction j'espère pouvoir vous vous
pouvez pouvoir vous convaincre pendant
les prochaines minutes de la nécessité
de continuer à raconter des histoires de
continuer en lire de continuer à en
écouter fil de ma construction je vous
disais ça peut paraître un peu logique
pour certains moi j'ai une mère instit
voilà qui m'obligeait allait
régulièrement à la bibliothèque
par exemple je ne pouvais renouveler mes
bandes dessinées que quand j'avais fini
mon roman
et puis bah j'ai un père aussi bourré
d'anecdotes
il faut le voir parler de rei de cochon
de deux pieds paquets de langue de boeuf
ça donne l'eau à la bouche
alors que admettons les abats c'est
quand même pas la matière la plus facile
mais dans ma famille le moment des repas
est un moment très spécifiques
auxquelles justement on s'échange
énormément d'anecdotes d'histoires c'est
un moment qui dure assez longtemps fil
de ma de ma construction effectivement
je suis premier de toutes les
générations
moi dans ma famille je premier des
enfants le premier des petits enfants le
premier des arrières petits enfants
autant vous dire que toute ma vie on a
bien pris le temps de masse qui côté on
a bien pris le temps de me raconter
beaucoup d'histoires jusqu'à même frôlé
mois
l'hyperactivité est la seule chose qui
me calmait c'était qu'on me confie un
livre adolescent j'ai surconsommer les
médias c'était pour moi une ouverture
sur le monde je viens d'un petit patelin
et comme ça je je je me souviens le par
exemple je tressaille est au fond de ma
couette à écouter une radio associative
du coin qui avait une fréquence
temporaire
il arrive que des radios ne peuvent
émettre que jusqu'à un certain jour par
exemple à minuit et 7 fréquences et
ensuite redispatcher avec des plus
grosses radios et bien j'ai goûté au
fond de ma couette cette radio se
barricader à minuit et faire un siège
comme ça toute la nuit jusqu'à ce que
les flics chargent le lendemain tout ça
en direct ça voilà c'est ce type
d'histoire en fait qui m'a qui m'a
construit même ma grand mère
même ma grand mère m'a raconté des
histoires elle m'a appelé un jour elle
m'a dit tiens ce serait bien que tu
viennes ya des gosses qui font du bruit
en ville alors se boira d'une petite
phrase un peu anecdotique ce qu'il faut
quand même savoir cette manne grand-mère
est espagnol elle habite dans le centre
bretagne ces fameux gosse qui font du
bruit en ville en fait ce sont les
vielles charrues le plus grand festival
de france faut comprendre la volonté
d'intégration du cou de ma grand mère
mais surtout elle me dit de venir
puisqu'il ne faut pas que les gens du
coin continue à passer pour des ploucs
ce festival là c'était il ya c'était il
ya 20 ans ce coup de fil de ma
grand-mère chier été festivalier
j étais ensuite bénévoles aujourd'hui
j'y présente depuis une dizaine d'années
les conférences de presse artistes dans
les premières éditions ou vieilles
charrues j ai notamment croiser les
têtes raides
voilà alors été très c'est la chanson
réaliste sais pas si vous connaissez moi
j'étais plutôt rock adolescents pas
forcément dans mes goûts je sais même
plus pourquoi j'ai été voir le concert
mais il s'est passé un truc incroyable
à la fin de ce concert là la foule était
impassible et voyez comme tout d'un coup
elle fait corps
tout s'est embrasé
et je pense que comme moi il y avait
plein de gens qui connaissaient pas du
tout cette cette chanson et je sais pas
si vous avez fait attention là la
difficulté qu'a le chanteur à contenir
ses larmes à ce qu'il voit là c'est
quasiment l'équivalent du stade de
france sauf que c'est pas le stade de
france au tour seul stade de france
devant ils les voient c'est en plein
jour je me rappelle chaque fois que je
veux cette vidéo je me rappelle
l'émotion que j'ai ressentie à ce moment
là où je me suis fait cueillir cueillir
justement un endroit où je ne m'y
attendais pas sur un style pour lequel
je ne m'y attendais pas et bien c'est
pour ça que j'ai voulu en faire mon
métier je me suis dit 7,7 ce qui s'est
passé là j'ai envie de le raconter
et je les raconte et depuis énormément
pourquoi j'ai fait ce métier journalisme
je trouve que vivre pour raconter c'est
quand même un bouchon de vie est
effectivement journalisme ça permet
d'avoir accès à des expériences parfois
un peu plus inédites aller dans des dans
des lieux qui sont plus fermés comme par
exemple raconté l'histoire de deux
inspecteurs clouzot si un inspecteur
clouseau c'est un instinct duo gascon de
rock qu'ont décidé de pousser assez loin
l'indépendance ils sont leur propre
tourneurs managers et la belle et puis
un jour ce duo alors qu'ils sont en
concert en chine en marge de
l'exposition universelle d'affaires 2010
ils prennent conscience que peut être
cette indépendance ne va pas assez loin
et bien c'est type reprendront une ferme
aujourd'hui la moitié de leur vie est
une et le travail de fermiers l'autre
moitié est atteint travail de rocker
c'est là on voyage et à travers à
travers le monde c'est vraiment un
modèle qui marche
mais au lieu de de faire une interview
lambda d'un groupe comme ça j'ai passé
le week-end avec eux à la ferme
j'ai raconté leur travail dans leur
quotidien comment le rock
comment le blues venaient de ses racines
de cette fierté d'un deux mains
calleuses
là ce contexte il fut important
n'hésitez pas il n'est une énième
interview copier-coller qu'on peut
parfois parfois trouvé ce contexte il
est important pour moi il est important
pour pour raconter les choses pour
mettre un petit peu d'émotion il ya un
autre contexte qui m'a marqué c'est un
jour où je couvrais un festival à à
madagascar
en marge de ce festival là un soir on
apprend qu'il ya un très grand artiste
qui ce qui se produit dans le cadre du
bal de la police pareil ça paraît pas
non plus très excitant c'est un
commissariat qui est en hauteur nous
sommes avec des gardes du corps qui ne
voulait pas se rendre à ce commissariat
nous comprendrons un petit peu plus tard
pourquoi on a vécu une espèce de montée
des marches un petit peu comme à cannes
mais sans applaudissements
le regard haineux dans un silence pesant
un silence incroyable une montée
incroyablement longue et puis on arrive
comme ça dans cette dans cette pièce
sans ouverture cette pièce bétonné
caisse avec des poteaux l'info quand
même s'imaginer que du coup nous sommes
trois quatre français je suis le seul
journaliste autour de nous comme autour
de ce cercle il y a nos gardes du corps
il y à tous les flics malgache qui sont
aussi autour de nous mais eux ne regarde
pas la scène il regarde nous et pendant
tout le concert
et là viendra sur scène une femme
kareyce dollar qui sort de la pénombre
et qui chantera alwil survive de gloria
gaynor complètement délavé de ces
arrangements discours etc
j'ai pris je pense conscience de la
vraie portée des paroles ce jour là
et je ne la verrai plus jamais pareil
autant que vous penserez à chaque fois
aux fesses de sting et vous pouvez me
remercier à chaque fois que vous
écouterez roxane de police ce contexte
il est important puisque le lendemain
j'ai pu voir sur un sur un petit parking
voilà il sait lui degré des gosses qui
ne connaissaient leur batteur que depuis
quinze jours et qui ont fait un garage
punk rock assez incroyable à ces
authentiques mais surtout au regard de
ce contexte je comprenais leur colère je
comprenais l'absence d'espoir et j'ai pu
raconter cette cette histoire là et
quelques mois plus tard six mois plus
tard ce groupe qui s'appelle se disent
règne ils ont été révélation des
transmusicales
pourquoi je je je raconte tout ça pour
quoi
l'émotion selon moi elle me semble
important dans les airs et si vous
n'êtes pas sans ignorer qu'il y à une
crise de la presse
actuellement je trouve c'est selon moi
en fait que la presse a perdu le goût de
ces récits là on est dans une
information assez courtes uniforme
on vous parle souvent de choses que vous
connaissez déjà
quand est-ce que c'est la dernière fois
que vous avez tressaillez devant un
papier c'est quand la dernière fois que
ça vous a ému difficile à chercher
voilà moi ça me semble important et
c'est pour ça il ya deux ans que j'ai
voulu créer une chaîne youtube parce que
j'ai été inondé de ces histoires là j'ai
envie de les raconter ces histoires là
et voyez comme quand je vous regarde
dans les yeux
à quel point cette histoire incarné
prend beaucoup plus d'importance
et puis j'ai découvert aussi autre chose
à travers cette chaîne youtube où chaque
vendredi je raconte l'histoire d'une
chanson est évidemment avec son contexte
c'est la proximité à travers les
commentaires à travers les mails je me
suis mis à avoir un lien avec les gens
qui me regardait et enseigne à échanger
j'ai appris autant d'eux que j'espère
qu'ils apprennent deux mois échanger
débattre aussi puis parfois se fâcher
mais ce rapport je ne l'avais plus dans
l'écriture j'adore toujours l'écriture
mais il ne faut plus que les
journalistes soient une caste comme ça
assez inaccessible ce travail d'aller
retour est aussi intéressant pourquoi il
est important de continuer à raconter
des histoires alors peut-être vous vous
rappelez que quand j'étais adolescent je
j'avais tendance à enjoliver ces
histoires évidemment est le journaliste
fut une vraie thérapie pour ça parce que
le journalisme m'a appris que les
histoires vraies c'est plus fort que le
narrateur une histoire c'est juste
destiné à être transmis
c'est destiné justement à cet échange
c'est l'histoire qui est transmis c'est
pas du tout le narrateur toutes les
civilisations ont transmis leurs
connaissances fia les histoires c'est ce
fameux feux de camp ancestrale instinct
art oratoire l'art oratoire il est très
ancien
on apprenait aussi un petit peu plus tôt
parfois dans les écoles la rhétorique
l'art de bien parler et puis les
histoires ça permet aussi parfois
d'apprendre sans avoir l'impression
d'apprendre ça c'est assez intéressant
les histoires ça permet aussi de changer
d'avis moi par exemple il ya à peu près
un an
on m'a proposé d'écrire sur le hard rock
café lait hard rock café voilà si jolie
sauf que nous devions perdre au café ça
reste une marque toute puissante apporté
dans 74 pays des casinos ou des cafés
une enseigne américaine quoi de burgers
oui mais ici je vous dis que depuis dix
ans cette enseigne
elle appartient à des amérindiens et oui
c'est une tribu amérindienne qui a
racheté les arbres café les séminoles de
floride les séminoles de floride ce sont
eux qui ont créé le premier casino
amérindiens qui m'attend une source de
revenus assez commune pour les tribus
ses casinos ils ont permis de financer
des emplois stables ils ont permet de
financer la retraite des études
supérieures des projets agroalimentaires
de l'écotourisme cette marque le havre
au café elle était racheté pour 1
milliard de dollars un milliard de
dollars d'autant plus que des singles de
floride et ils ont vécu des guerres
comme beaucoup d'américains et eux-mêmes
trois guerres sanglantes sauf qu'ils
n'ont jamais perdu
jamais on leur a même jamais proposé de
traiter de p ils s'appellent eux-mêmes
le peuple a vaincu peuple a vaincu
rebellion rock
et peut même là vous c'est une
reconquête des états unis burger par
burger c'est une reconquête de l'ouest
aussi économique que symbolique
mais il s'agit pas d'être journaliste
pour raconter ce type d'histoire et on
l'a vu aujourd'hui on peut être auteur
de bande dessinée on peut être
bibliothécaire en pet sportif peu
importe peu importe un bon professeur
et on en a parfois eu un bon professeur
pour vous faire aimer n'importe quelle
matière pour moi un bon journaliste de
c'est celui qui convaincra votre mère
d'acheter les bootleg de bob dylan alors
qu'elle ne connaissait pas le nom du
chanteur cinq minutes avoir en avoir
commencé le papier parce que pour moi la
vraie intelligence c'est de pouvoir
parler simplement de choses compliquées
alors en conclusion la continuer à
raconter d'histoires embêter vos petits
enfants dit leur qui a des gosses qui
font du bruit en ville
vraiment saoulé vos potes emmenez vos
enfants la bibliothèque
non tu ne rendra pas des bandes
dessinées tant que tu n'as pas fini ton
roman ok les histoires ça peut changer
la vie moi en tout cas ça change la
mienne ça peut même être une étincelle
d'inspiration et après tout qu'est-ce
que vous êtes venu faire vous
aujourd'hui
ici dans le cas du tedx 6 n'écoutez
histoire
[Applaudissements]